hello everybody welcome come on in we're
going to get started in just a little
bit
uh the room is filling in everyone's
having a great uh
start of their um their hot back summer
i think this thing everyone's saying
right now
but i was doing well hope everyone's um
starting to feel a little bit better
from the past year um and starting to
get ready to uh you know
get slowly back to normal for those of
you that are in countries that are
highly vaccinated i know we feel
coming from all over the world so people
who are in other countries that are not
as highly vaccinated
i hope that you stay safe until um it
happens
um i hope everyone's just doing great
with this year it's almost
hopefully for the lights at the end of
the tunnel i know it for an american
perspective
it looks like it's getting closer to the
end but i know for other people it might
be farther
so good luck folks i hope i hope it ends
soon for everybody
first up as you always do at this meetup
i always like to say who is hiring now
as we've learned over the past year plus
you can't all jump up and shout and tell
me who's hiring
so uh what we're going to do is if you
want to hire somebody
go to the slack channel um the link for
slack
r slack is i'll put it right here in the
chat
it's nyhakgar.org oh man i screwed it up
already let me do it again folks
okay that looks better i had two slashes
before if you go to nyhacker.org
slack.html there's a link to join the
meetup slack which has lots of other
stuff besides job announcements
but if you're looking to hire somebody
posted in the job postings channel
job dash postings go in there post a job
hopefully you'll find a good employee
if you're looking to get a job go in
there
and look for job postings
speaking of hiring my company lander
analytics we are hiring and know that
not everyone can announce it but since
i'm on screen i'll tell you that i'm
hungry
um we are looking for a few roles we're
looking for like a technical sales role
or a full-on sales role too we have a
few sales roles
and we're looking for a data scientist
linux administrator role
so if you're looking for those jobs you
want to come look work for what i think
is a fun company and i think it's an
awesome boss
uh come talk to me you all know how to
find me right on slack
email twitter i'm findable in many many
ways so
come find me if you want to do sales or
data science rules or linux
administrator rules
i think it'll be a really fun company to
work for and i'm not biased in the
slightest
so i know we all can't be together and
it's really sad but keeping up tradition
i got my pizza all right this comes from
joe's pizza
i'll do the the cheese lock test cheese
is holding on very nicely
some good charring on the back side so i
hope everyone is enjoying their pizza
and let me know in the chat
uh where you are um let me know where
your pizza's coming from or whatever
snacks you want to have tonight
selena had a cheese croissant that
sounds out that'd be tasty that sounds
great
daniel chen you miss new york city pizza
i know you do look we're getting you
back up to new york soon though
um anybody else let me know where you're
eating or what you're drinking or
whatever you're doing let's
we can't do this for real so let's at
least try to pretend like we are
being convivial together all right well
while i wait for everyone else to tell
me where they've eaten pizza from
buffalo
right uh boston your pizza looks like
pork chops and rice
that's very interesting looking pizza i
like it
all right um and we have nicolas from
buffalo so anyone hope everyone's
enjoying their food i know
you don't come here for the food you
come here for the stats you stay for the
food that's what we'll say
all right so a few things you can be
doing virtually oh
tommy's getting his pizza looks like a
beer we have steak bob and ganus bowl
that sounds great
a pomegranate white tea in the dc area
pomegranate yt sounds very refreshing
devin
i i'm with you on that i can dig that
sounds very impressive i have tmv right
now
all right um some things coming up other
events you can attend
uh this week i believe starting
wednesday actually might have already
started i'm not quite sure i shouldn't
know the specifics
you can check the email i sent out to
everybody last week i believe
there's a conference for neo4j it's a
graph database
they have their conference and the i
think their workshops were last week
but the conference itself is this week
so you can sign up if you want more
information
it is available at meetup.com in our
event channel i think nicole will post
it in the events channel
or she's already posted there um just go
there click that link i know there's
definitely dan chen is here missing new
york city pizza
he'll be uh moderating some of the stuff
there so you can check him out and check
out this great
great event
speaking of conferences we announced it
formally tickets are on sale
the new york r conference we are very
very excited to be hosting the new york
r conference both
in person and virtual in september
we had a calendar snafu so we changed a
few things on the schedule
the workshops will now be september 1st
and then the conference itself will be
september 9th through 10th
yes i know their week apart that makes
it hard for people if you're traveling
to new york city
but everything will also be offered
virtually so if you want to do the
workshop virtually then attend the
conference in person or flip it around
or do both one way or the other you can
so remember folks september 1st and
september 9th through 10th
uh the new york r conference and nicole
just posted a link
uh because i am a little challenged for
doing that apparently posting links
she posted it in um the chat r stats dot
a i slash
nyr stephen you're coming to new york
that's exciting we're glad to have you
there
um and if anyone here you're all members
of the meetup this conference grew out
of the meetup
those who've been around for a long time
know that i said we do a meet-up every
month let's do a conference
and a two-day event so for you members
of this meetup there
is a discount code ny hack r same as our
website
that's our slogan our logo our
catchphrase whatever the right word is
use code ny hack r to get your 20
discount
we are very excited about that and i see
oh
selena she's told me she's coming she's
a former speaker oh and selena
selena is giving artwork that will be
auctioned off not sure she knew that yet
but she did it last time
uh selena we want to auction your art
again so please uh get it to us and
we're doing
every year at this conference for the
past few years since thomas levine
started it
we auction off art um
made by the art community and all the
money goes to the our foundation
and i believe these another foundation i
can't
remember the name of right now but
definitely our foundation some examples
of the art we've auctioned in the past
is actually
um by jacqueline knowles behind me
greeting from statistics
i got this commission later on a
painting by vivian peng and i believe
behind emil
we've also auctioned off in the past
also uh the neural network layers that's
like such a perfect speaker to have here
with the art already
thank you emil for having it all right
other events we have coming up
we have a stan workshop every year we've
done a stand workshop with jonah gabriel
andrew gellman rob sanguchi and a bunch
of other rotating people coming through
um we're very excited to do this again
this year it's going to be virtual
because we're not quite ready to open up
in person yet
july 14th through 16th i will hopefully
successfully
post the link inside the uh the chat
to this let's see if this works all
right
that's the link to learn more about the
stan workshop we do it every year
every year it's completely different
content me and my team attend every year
and every year we're like oh wow we did
not know any of that because they keep
changing the content
and we've actually seen attendees come
repeatedly because they keep owning new
stuff
so if you want to learn about stan which
is bayesian markov chain monte carlo
come to this it's always a great time
jonah gravity's going to be leading it i
believe rob tranguchi will be assisting
and adrian dominant will do his normal
pop-in like he does every year
we are very excited about that the day
before the stand workshop
we have the july meetup with
sean taylor on july 13th that'll be
announced in the coming days
sean taylor will be i don't even know
what he's been talking about but it's
sean taylor so we're all going to check
it out because it's awesome
all right uh so sean taylor who's spoken
a few times at the meetup before and
he's spoken at the conference
will be speaking virtually at the meetup
july 13th so everyone you'll get that
announcement coming up very soon
then in august we will have ian cook
speaking virtually at the meetup so we
have the next two months plan it's so
nice when things are planned in advance
august will be ian cook we are really
looking forward to that
and then i'm really excited about this
we don't have any details yet
but we will be returning to an in-person
and virtual meetup in september
we always like to have a meet-up same
week as the conference again
due to our calendar screw up it'll be
the same week as the workshop this time
uh so september 1st or 2nd we're going
to have an in-person
meetup and we'll be doing it virtually
and in person we'll do both to make sure
everyone can still participate
we're very excited about returning to
in-person meetups to coincide with the
in-person conference
now we're not going in person until
september because
i know a lot of things are opening up
especially new york city i think they're
having fireworks tonight
to celebrate new york city opening up
again but
we're not quite ready to do it yet one
of the main reasons is we can't get
space to host us yet most of our all the
companies that usually host us
are not comfortable hosting until
september and even then we don't have it
fully planned out yet we do fully intend
to come
with the meetup to coincide the
conference in september but
if you work for a company and you have
office space
please let me know if you would like to
host the meetup physically and let us
in your office to have us in there we
need about at least a hundred seats
more i think we'll feel more people
gonna be coming um than usual
we used to be able to fill a room with
300 seats but we don't have that much
space anymore
so if anyone has a company that would
like to host the meetup
let me know be in touch with me on
twitter on slack by email by
is the message by any way you want let
us know if you have office space
somewhere
um preferably in midtown or below that's
to make it easy for people to get to and
get to the train or subway afterwards
let me know if you can host
us that'd be really great because we're
always in search of space
until then we are still virtual and we
will continue to be
hybrid going forward i'd like to thank
ecohealth alliance for providing the
zoom
uh so thank you um noam ross and
emma oh i'm forgetting your last name
mendelson i think i'm so sorry
thank you noam and emma for providing
the zoom link for us this entire past 14
months
it's been really really helpful so i
want to say thank you
as we get started if we have
questions for our speaker we obviously
can't ask the questions directly
so use the chat right here in zoom
or send a question to
the slack channel called monthly meetup
chat
there is a channel called monthly meetup
chat where if you guys folks sorry and
you folks just want to
talk about what's going on or ask
questions do it in there
and it was a question for a mill i will
ask it at the end i'll collate all the
questions and then i will ask at the
very end
and ask it on behalf of everybody
because we can all jump right in
so again if you want to ask a question
post it here in zoom
or post it in the monthly meetup chat in
slack
so that's a lot of announcements key
takeaways you want a job posting the
jobs
eat your pizza neo4j conference this
week our conference in september stand
workshop next month
meet up with sean taylor next month meet
up at ian cook in august
returning to in person and virtual for
almost everything for at least for this
meetup group in september that's a lot
of stuff
so with that i hope everyone had a good
time
um and hopefully i hope you're going to
have a good time and um i'll
bring us the next speaker who is very
appropriate to speak on this topic given
that
um his history of text recipes uh and
hope everyone's gonna have a good time
enjoying this please everyone give a
warm virtual
welcome to emil thank you so much
jared and thanks for having me
it is wonderful this is such a
flawlessly automized meetup continuing
for years and years
thank you i will be talking about test
pre-processing
my name is emilio wietfeldt if you have
a hard time pronouncing it remember that
both the h and d is silent i know it
just makes life a little bit more
exciting when
names aren't pronounced as their win
so just a little bit about me i am a
clinical data analyst at cellular health
i'm also spending a little bit of my
part my own time i'm teaching
at american university i'm teaching
statistical
machine learning and i'm trying to do
useful society models it's very exciting
i'm also a maintainer of almost a dozen
different
patterns on train the top is usually a
role
around color palettes working with tests
and tidy models uh
interactions and i'm also
julia and i are working on the boot call
supervised machine learning for test
analysis
just find a mouthful which wouldn't find
a shorter title that
really explained what it's about and
that one's coming out very soon wait for
the end of the talk a little bit more
information about that
i'm located in southern california
and uh with my wife been here for since
2017 and i'm living here
with my three cats and i'm sure
everybody want to know they want
pictures so here we have we have
presto orion whittles their siblings
they're around two years old
and they're very happy here they're a
little hard right now because we're
having a heat wave
all right so interesting aside let's
step onto it
so i thought it was appropriate to start
this drone
from hadley with him which states that
most of data science is counting
and sometimes dividing and i find this
to be
ring true quite a lot but i want to
modify it a little bit
because i also think that most of text
pre-processing
is pounding and sometimes dividing and
this is really what
i want to talk about today so the first
question we really have is
what are we counting so we have some
tests coming in and what are we really
talking so let's start with just
example of some sets i have this there
are catholics animals never did on train
but it has a lot of really long form
explanation
of different animals so if you look at
this example of
what a fever is we see a lot of tabs
different things and i'm stating earlier
that we want to count something in this
text
so if we loaded it a little bit we might
think oh we can like chop
off like chop it around a little bit and
you can count
that so one way if you're just thinking
it might be a good idea to just chop it
up by
sentence by sentence but what you really
run into if you chop
everything into sentences is
most of them tend to be unique
so the first sentence he was the most
well known for the distinctive form
building
that is even rivers and streams is very
much likely
a completely unique sentence unless it's
being topic-tasted from
wherever i got this data set and any
sentences
that will be repeated might not have
that much information
so we want to find a smaller unit that
is easily countable another thing we
could do
is count individual characters or
letters in this case
for letters and punctuation and numbers
and we certainly to do this however we
lose so much information it is because
we took that a distribution of how often
different characters appear
but it's it it doesn't really tell us
that much it might help us
a little bit with language
identification
the tasks different languages use
different
words which then i then use different
letters so we did a slightly different
letter distribution
but i just said that different words
are being used differently across
different languages and domains so maybe
the idea of a word would be something
that they can count out and depend on
how we define the words and depending
on how talented you might be able to use
that information
later down the line so before i move on
i think it's very important that i give
a disclaimer
that everything i'll be talking about
right now
will use examples in english
and i think it's very important with
any kind of time you're working with
tabs to follow bender rule
which states that you always should say
what language you're working with
even if you're watching english because
the statement
we solved question and answering in text
is not equivalent to resolve question
answering
using english text so
even though english appears to be
everything that happens in
nlp it's very important that we state
upfront
what we're working with and also the
difficulty of different tasks
related to nlp and working with text
is going to be different depending on
what language you're writing with some
tests would be easier in english
and some of them are really hard so it
will be very hard to
do anything with a generalized sense
and lastly a small reminder that
the language is very much different than
text
and this you might if you are
testing someone that is significantly
younger than you you might have noticed
that
sometimes you that
disagreement about how to test with
everybody i'm in debate
i'm in that little middle spot of
knowing that people older than me will
use ellipses
as a natural pause and people younger
than me for using gypsies in testing as
a oh that doesn't really matter that
much so
a lot of things differ so just because
we're saying
we're solving this thing it's very
important we're working with text
and not languages and another thing just
drawing outside of
english there's many languages that
doesn't have a written style most likely
start as
spoken language and then some of them
will turn to green
so the goal of this process of test
pre-processing
and we say test pre-processing because
it's typically something
we have to do before we apply some of
our statistical machine learning models
is the task of
turning our tests so imagine that big
paragraph we saw before
it needs to be turned into numbers and
more specifically
it needs to change numbers because we
need something that's machine readable
most of those adjustable methods and
machine learning methods
requires the input to be numeric
one way or another and even
the some of the methods that can't say
it's things like that variables
will actually turn it into numbers down
the line just
hide it for you as a user interface
helping
and what uh i
like to find out in this turn text
numbers is that there will be some kind
of loss
along the way we lose some of the
information so this becomes
a
like a non-reversible transformation
much like we lose some information from
going to speech
into text because we don't have any of
the mannerisms we don't have
tone we lose a lot of things from going
from speech to text
we'll lose more by going from test
into numbers i also want to point out
that a lot of the things we're talking
about today
will be language and implementation and
mastered
and here i'm meaning language both in
the term
of the spoken language we're working
with but also the programming language
we're working with
but i'll be showing samples how to do
this
in test recipes because that is
what selfishly i think is one of the
best implementations
that can handle some of these things
so some of the existing packages to deal
with tests
in r this is what we're working with i
want to highlight
two of them we have a tidy test
and that one's here and they deal with
slightly different things society test
is a smaller package and
it does a really really great job of
doing eda
or what is also otherwise called test
mining
and also has some tools to work with top
modeling
but tidy test works
because the thai device
already exists so it's leveraging a lot
of tools
from the deep player tidier package
that allows us to seamlessly work
test and downplay so tidy test doesn't
stand alone it
advances the typos that eternal system
whereas transceiver is more of a whole
ecosystem approach
and it can do almost everything it
starts all the way from the beginning
ingestion data pre-processing all the
way to different kinds of modeling
everything happens in one frame right
now this is where i come in
test recipes tetrasqueeze tries to
handle
a couple of different things it is
limited at them to only do
processing or feature engineering so it
only
goes in this step of have the data and
turning it into numbers
everything after that it doesn't want to
do anything before it doesn't worldwide
it is part of the tiny model framework
in the sense that is an add-on package
to the recipes package
leveraging a lot of the
the hard work that has been happening
recipes and just
literally latches on and uses all the
great engineering that happens in there
another thing it doesn't create any
custom objects so if you can use recipes
and learn how to use recipes
even more or less seamlessly use test
recipes as well it doesn't require a lot
of
knowledge of strange objects it
technically has
custom objects but they're all used
internally so hopefully you can see
and by being part of recipes
it doesn't restrict us to only use tests
as features
so one thing i've noticed especially in
beginner
material around the web
if you look at something like test
classification something like that
they will only show you how to use test
to be features in some modeling later on
without mentioning that you can also use
non-test features alongside so this is
where
tesla's piece starts to shine
and you might think that this is the
whole
oh there's a lot of competing frameworks
i will develop a new one even more and i
can't
dispute this claim but i'm hoping that
what i have here is a worthwhile
companion in the uh text
pre-processing ecosystem
and just a couple of notes of why these
systems doesn't work
tidy test works really really well when
you're doing
test mining if you want to look at
what's happened if you want to
repeat the transformations later on
you run into issues since it's in a long
format it you need to take a lot of
steps to make sure that
it becomes that you don't lose
the sufficient information during batch
or wide format which is something
specific
handles francina's also breakfast the
whole
heathen system thing which would make it
really hard which would make it a little
harder to
work with
tiny models but you might did like a
clash of either systems
i have plans to interpret some of it
later down the line but it's
for me it made more sense to do a
smaller
building blood and the most important
thing that test resistance do
is they can learn transformation on some
data and apply the same transformations
to new data and this comes for free by
using recipes
and just to uh limit everything so talk
doesn't end up being
five hours i'm limiting myself
and test recipes to work with
uh tabular data so it doesn't do any
draftings with everything
starts and triples and then continues
and it comes a little bit from my like
personal development
uh philosophy that around
that something that good foundation then
always worked in the cutting edge
especially because
i feel that some of these idea that i'm
talking about
in this course isn't
explained very in-depth
other places so this is what i'm trying
to remedy
so if you just look right here we have
an example of a recipe
and i'm using on the animal's data set
so i just load it in
and if you notice there's a lot of
different steps
but what you will see is we start with
some steps
about some other variables we have a
fatter variable lifestyle and a numeric
variable mean
weight and we do some transformation on
those and then afterwards we
do some transformation to the test so
everything
can work together which is really the
power
of test recipes and
what we're really going on is we have
four steps more or less when we're doing
test three processing first step is
turning
the test into some smaller units we'll
talk those totans
then we can modify the totals or remove
some of the tokens we don't want
and lastly we'll take the tokens into
the amount
so these are the four steps uh
test uh pre-processing more or less
about and i'll go through them one by
one
so first we'll sort of tokenize safety
so that is almost always the first thing
you will do when you're watching the
test if you don't have if you're not
the only really other thing you to to do
is make sure that all your testing
coding is
done directly because that can be a very
big happen
down the line and totalization is really
the test of taking a bit of blob of text
and turn it into something smaller units
and something we can count
and this is some very important because
when we're working with tests we
generally
don't have a fixed width
that we can do so we have we can do a
little bit in something light
uh straight up as we're limited by 280
characters
but what we can't what what account
which is typically words for
other units don't have a limit of how
many
you can do so it becomes different we
want to
find a way to count something so
this is where we go to totalization and
the most common token is typically the
word
so we want to find a way to date our
test and
find out where the word is but there's
many different
options when you take into consideration
when you take our tests and
send it into words and
we're very fortunate thank you speaking
people because
the idea of what of what a word is
is quite clear but and we can actually
find that
just splitting our string by white space
works really really well by itself
but you will run into different things
that like what like a fire truck
this is one word two words there is
afternoon like there's a couple of words
that feels like there might be one word
for the technically split
and so on and so forth but generally
uh the idea that we can split very
easily
in english and this is not the case of
all languages
like that selena in the chat saying that
turkish if things are a little bit
different also chinese everything's
different because
the notion of a word can be one or more
more one or more glyphs so
totalization in english is quite an easy
test because
the default work quite well is to be a
very different case
in all languages so
here i'm taking my b right sample and
i'm just splitting it
by white space i'm just using a string
split
and this red is just
all by white space and we see that it
looks fairly well with that
what appears like words there's some
weird things on it like like
punctuations things should be lit down
here
the twits included the timer and strong
period but more or less
but more or less we've already did
pretty well
just by using spaces if you don't any
time class
but you know you've probably come around
come around and certainly say the total
nicest package
it provides a wide variety of totalizers
and the default totalized words works
really well as well with that something
that really looks like word
does a lot of splitting
unfortunately it is hard
to actually define these rules
so the tokens was uses
the word boundary algorithm and stringy
package
and here is the short outline
of what it actually tries to achieve and
the default documentation is many many
dozens of pages
explaining all the little things why it
works
white doesn't quite because there's a
lot of different
ad spaces to deal with but
this totalness was worked really well
but it also
is a vastly more complex method
but with that in mind there's a couple
of things we
take into consideration first of all
do we need to uh turn in the uppercase
letters
into lowercase we saw before we just do
that
we see in the first one beavers stay
uppercase
when we use much worse it does turn into
lowercase
so on sometimes where it's deforester
generally to load is
what does what information are we losing
when we turn properties letters into
lower text letters
that will depend on your test do you
really tell
in many in english
obvious letters usually means as a
proper noun or beginning of
sentence does that matter a lot
if you're working with someone that
likes to eat a lot if you want your test
with people that really like apple
products
but also really like to eat fruit you
might need
distinction between uppercase apple and
the lowercase apples
but sometimes you don't so that is
adjustment tool for you to make but it's
a choice you need to make because
that's it's a budgeting
different ways to do it that may or may
not
uh should be butted together
another thing is punctuation how do you
deal with it
a general default just to remove baby
compensation
punctuation but sometimes that can be
important as well
sometimes removing punctuation can even
split up words that
were all wise hyphenated there's a bunch
of different translations right there
and that's what i said before well how
do you deal with non-word
terrorists not what characters
inside words and when we've got a
non-word it's like what if it's not a
outfla
alpha just the alphabet
parents character so in a word like
don't it is a
attraction but should we keep it as one
word or two words
there's a bunch of different
possibilities right there and what do
you do tampon world
and multi-waves how do you
deal with this it's like this is can be
very important things like pronouns
or other names of more things
the white house is for many people
one unit it's not quite in a house it is
a specific unit
and if you're not careful about how we
deal with this
it doesn't pop up as easy
um
so uh that's all problems as well and
i'm not attentive
the answer to most of this a lot of
the translations right here will
turn will be directly related to
the data you're working with and what
domain you're using
but i want to highlight these are things
that that should be transceived
another thing right here we have a just
a short
vector of strings for flowers bush and
flowers
and we would imagine that if we tape on
this we just say like
two flowers and one bush but now that i
run it
we see that there's two different
flowers
and what is happening right here is the
first flowers
had a literature they're combining
the f and l into one
character and this thing looked really
really nice for some
types of presentations because it was a
little bit more sleek
but it can mean that you like basically
it the computer doesn't know by default
these are different so
um that's another thing these words will
not be town
these two flowers will not be counted as
the same words
and you can but there's different ways
of dealing with this as well
a couple of more things one thing like
how do you even begin to talk about
slang
and domain knowledge i like to think of
the main knowledge to really
emphasize what it is is by saying that
everything you see on wikipedia
will be vastly different everything you
see on twitter
the way we're speaking is different we
don't have a word count
on wikipedia if you use slang
punctuation starts mattering a lot
more in social media
posts in a personal things so
what how do we learn things together
this is
probably more of a post like more of an
after totalization
thing we say all these wows should be
turned into one
but well there are different vowels or
cipher gloves will matter like 10
sometimes matter and also what you have
is there's only one person doing this
super long wow
if we don't lump it in it might not have
it might not show the signal if
otherwise have
if all the slightly different
limitations
are being counted separately and lastly
to really like show why text is a pain
to work with all the time
is that how do we deal with emojis like
emojis words are they
modifiers here we have let's get some
tattoos we're just taking
the tattoo replacing it with the emoji
for tattoo
it appears like this most people can
easily understand what that is and this
is just a
real replacement but the test i love you
a little red heart everybody also
understands but the
the know what quantities this emoji has
is quite different no one is saying i
love you
heart that's the thing it becomes a
modifier
to um
through sentences so it can change quite
a lot
so the the phrase you're out of your
mind
sad like like angry face is quite a bit
different and
you know out of your mind happy
um happy hearts face uh
and this a lot of this can become
this like this idea of emojis i think
can a lot of times
be used to
inject passion of the tone that we lost
in
turning something into the test and what
i'm really trying to say is that the
domain you're working in matters
so uh preprocessing test pipeline
that works in a little test framework
it's not going to work as well when you
apply to social media posts
or to to job post things
or anything else it just depends and you
need to
know where the differences are you need
to know have someone
on your team that understands you're
doing
so you can adequately adjust
and the way the test is trying to deal
with this technology that there's
many many ways to do this and
we'll let you uh do what has
a couple of different defaults and
helpful ways to do it
but doesn't tie you down um
so we defaulted tokenizers you can pass
in your owns we also have bindings
to other languages or even packages
like other languages and other packages
and even languages
so uh default tokenizers service words
you can also pass in some of the
arguments if you don't want a strip
punctuation
and you don't want it anything to notice
you can modify the original
um certainizer if you wrote your own
tokenizer so if i wrote a function
called my it makes a totalizer
you pass it in and that tokenizer will
be used
and it will be saved in the recipe so
when you apply it then later
it will know we can also use the sparsi
tokenization engine
sparsi is a wonderful
python library to do test
test word and the sparsia package tracer
binding
in r we can use that underneath but as
well it
did much more rich to organization
with some laws in
uh in speed sometimes
there's also this tokenization idea of
bytecoin coding it there's a different
idea of what a word is it
finds common strings of characters
we have that as well and we even have
support for methods where we have
trained models that do totalize without
type
we can pass in a pipe
model the oct model
intel recipe and that is the one that we
use
and if you have any anything any other
tokens
you want support what is a little harder
please reach out we're happy to
add as much uh many useless as possible
stemming so stemming is
but as a title but actually what i
wanted to talk more about
is the add-on of modifying tokens
once they become tokens so we started
tokenizer
it splits the test into many smaller
things
typically works but it can be other
things as well syllables
and we want to modify them in some way
or another
and the most common way you want to
modify them is
to reduce cardinality so we have a bunch
of different tokens
that some of them are kind of saying the
same thing
it could be um
[Music]
some lotis orbitals but we also have
things like
house and houses so is there
do your model need a distinction between
water houses
but counting a house and topping houses
if
you don't want a distinction stemming
might be one of those options to do
so ah also in english we have like two
main ways to polar stemmer
which is this algorithm outlining the
different steps you can do
to remove ending so most of stemming
takes a word and removes things from the
end
which was a very english thing to do
because
lot of beginnings means a lot and even
more simpler
ways of stamp is just removing s's
at the end this is very much simple
algorithm
but can also work fairly well and
the way i like to think of it is we have
a bunch of different tokens
and they each have a bucket but we're
timing them in we're dating
have some factory water
that it in the corresponding budget
so the stemming is more or less the act
of
combining budgets that should be the
same
a bunch of differences doing this here
i'm just showing
three different like four not three
different ways
first tell them we're seeing the
original word
uh the second column we are
removing the s verb telling we're
working
by like like plural endings
and the last one we're doing the portal
stemming
and we see that there's some differences
in what happens to these words
noticeably the porta stemmer doesn't
always produce valid words in the
end and it's doing this to help
combine things we see that a lot of
times y
turns into i if it's in the end the
porous demo can
remove many characters but it's a way to
try
to combine things back down and
different methods a few different things
the porta stemmer has
other foreign removal
algorithm is very english so it probably
doesn't work about power languages
the polar stemmer is tailor-made to
write in english
but there's other um
there's similar algorithms written for
other languages
and this is just another example of why
it's really important
that you need someone on your team that
also knows
the language you're working with because
it could be that if you applied this
remove ending as
algorithm some other languages you might
lose a lot of information
this would be like the difference that
everything makes for certain words
and these are very easy to apply as well
the test piece defaults to
the portal stemmer which is implemented
in the snowball c
it is fun factoid
it's tall snowball because originally
they wanted to
call the nephew stripper and
someone told him that knight did not
have been the best idea
somebody emit that so they found a
potentially less offensive wire so they
want to snowball
yeah so it can default to apply to the
the border stemmer uh you can also
pass in the phone stemming function if
you have ones you want to remove
ending ss you can do that easily as well
and
there's also this idea of limitation
so this is a so most stemmers will be
some kind of algorithm in like the if
else
statement waste is hard coded and it is
very simplistic and more importantly it
was very fast
because a lot of them can be written as
a
record or two limitation is the next
step where we are trying to a lot of
times
build a model that learns the structure
tries to learn
the patterns and the data and removes
some
endings and we have a couple of
implementations of this we can use
asparsi
the implementation has trained model in
it and a butt pipe
also is a trained model so the way we
can do this
is if we set the engine
uh to sparse here
in step totalized then you can later use
step lemma and it will
pull out the limitation of those words
so the first limitalization happens at
totalization
time using spatial we are it is
it's strengthened out this way and you
can do this for all our
limitation methods so far we only have
support
for starcia and butterfly but
i'm trying to add more when we go along
and there's all the things we can do you
can also pass
in custom functions to step stem
to do any kind of transformation you
want
the next thing i want to talk about
which
is total start works not asking you to
stop
um i want to say a controversial
topic mostly because there's a lot of
ambiguity of what it really means and
this is really my session
why i want to talk about removing wires
so we started off splitting things into
words
then we turned and modified some of them
mostly with
the remove endings but that's the thing
you can do in english
there might be other things to do other
languages my stock works
section is we want to remove words
so i want to stop at 24 stopwatch
and to really explain what stop words
are let's
just go to the internet because that's
where everybody gets all the information
from
all the time so the first one we have
the natural language processing useless
word
data are referred to as stop words
in computing stop words are words that
are filtered out before
or after the natural language data are
processed
or stop words otherwise in any language
which does not add
much meaning to sentence it can safely
be ignored without sacrificing the
meaning of the sentence so
this is how i tend to look when
i read the statements because it gives
the illusion
that working with stop words
are very easy and if you just remove all
the words it is
no problem whatsoever another thing some
of those
accepts i saw was sometimes in even
larger articles
or books most of
what will be what they thought about in
the is all the discussion
about starbucks in uh
in julian iceberg um
we did see the whole chapter just to
stop works because
we felt that we really needed that kind
of attention and that's really why
what is stopwatch video in my view i
think
that stop words are low information
words
then that contribute little value
to the test at hand and
i think that the information over it
leaves us on a continuum
there's two things i wanted away from
the first sentence first one is
low information i mean a lot of
different things i'm never saying
something that's no information
something
low and it's the value added
is dependent on the task so let's let me
show
what i really mean for some pictures so
we look at this test on the right side
i'm doing some
visualization and each rectangle
represents a word
and i'm saying hi words will be bright
and low
high information words will be bright
low information words will not be bright
the first thing to think about is all
the words
containing the the same information how
they know like that
definitely are some words that contain
more it also doesn't appear to be
random about it what happens
and like there's no way of saying or not
but as told of always it totally would
have a high
variance information to like the
diamonds in the rough
so most of the words no information
tuple here and there a lot of
information that's one way you can have
it
another way to be this like low variance
kind of
information where we did little clusters
of high
information and like thistles just a
different way of thinking about it
and ideally what we think about we have
these words
and some words have a lot of information
and some words
have less and less and less and removing
stuff
stopwatch
will have this total line so we think
that we're removing stopwatch and just
removing everything else
but in reality you probably end up with
something like this so you're
hitting a cut off and you're picking
most of the
no information requests but
you will eventually unless you're very
very careful
also pick up some high information wires
you can always slide it around to try to
hit
like different sections or where it is
but it's hard to really find
the right total so we handle this in two
ways
or combine them we have pre-made lists
so that you find a stopwatch list out
there
you pull things out of it or you can
hand make the list
alright with handmade handmade thing you
just find all your words and fine
make the list all the words you don't
want to include and remove those
because there's a bunch of problems with
hangmate list in general
i talked about handmade lists as very
easy well constructed
there's very little ambiguity but there
is
quite a lot of different english topic
lists
out there and this is just some of the
ones out there
another thing that can become very
important
is that the stopwatch list are sensitive
to the way you totalized it
the way you tab utilize the words and
if you did stemming before or after so
if you're using a previous stopwatch
list
make sure that it matches everything
that happened
up to that point
sorry like that if you ever need to work
with a non-english subway list
basically hire someone
that know that language so you
like use the language and that's even
just generally if you wear
textbooks test have someone at least
some one person on the team that
actually knows the language
otherwise you get into a whole host of
trouble
and when it comes down to i want you to
look at the stopwatch list
and if it wasn't for time i would have
to slide
five more times repeatedly adrenal
jumping out at you because this is
really really important you need to look
at your stopwatch list and i'm having a
little twist
to explain why so i'm trying to function
stop word twist
so i'm giving you half a minute to type
in the chat
which one you think is the odd one out
in this list
of words if you want to you can join the
chat
say which one to which one of these four
words
doesn't appear to have a
relation to the other words and it's
fine if you don't
want to but it's just oh wait i started
the wrong timer
but in my china start on mine
so the odd one out here is
she is and this one spot one up it
doesn't appear on
smart stopwatch list whereas the other
three
appears so that's already like hey that
seems weird
that the two first stop
two first words and this list doesn't
appear together
next we have some other ones you then
have half min if you want to
join we have vowel b fifi and system 1
i'm looking for the one word that
doesn't appear to match
anything else seeing
and there's no way of you actually
knowing which one is unless you've seen
this talk before
because it will be like all these words
how we are
like they shouldn't none of them feels
like no information words
and the tourette answer here is 50.
because 50 was part of
a stop work list included inside
headline that was
undefeated for three years so
everybody that used this stopwatch list
using siteheadland we moved
50 but not 50.
and last one we have these long words
i would say that all of these words
appear to be highly
informational like it seems weird that
these would even be anywhere
close to a stopwatch list but
nevertheless
that's why this part this question is
on this twist and
yeah so like we have to substantially
successfully
sufficiently and statistically
which one's the weird one and with that
is statistically that error
correctly found in the chat because this
one doesn't appear in the stopwatch
iso list whereas the other three do
appear
so if you're using the iso include
stopwatch list you're having quite a bit
list
of wires that would be removed
um so general idea removing words is
removing
words you don't want to do one of the
things to be high frequency right high
frequency words tend to not have a lot
of information in it
just wires like ah and
or it the they that was appear a lot i
did work more
gluing today we can also remove low
frequency words because
if it only appears once in a hundred
thousand documents
can you really use it as signal for
later modeling positive noise
and it also removes stopwatch if you use
steps upwards
it removes the snowball
set i was very hesitant about having a
default just don't
think that removing stopwatch is always
necessary but
the snowball one is this smallest most
commonly known one
you can also specify other lists
and this is using the stopwatch package
so we can also have
other languages lists as well i always
admit
creating your own it works better
you can also filter according to
things about the data so here we can say
only keep the tokens that appear at
least 10 times
and also remove totems that
appears too many times these are very
heavy-handed
methods so you need to make sure you're
not removing things you shouldn't
and for computational reasons reasons we
can also
filter to only keep the most common
thousand two thousand words simply
because when we turn this into
a table in the end if you don't
use a filter for the number of totals we
get a very very large
sparse data set that sometimes doesn't
fit in memory
so we start with ending which are
totally betting which
is not the stain that you spin bettings
but what is basically turning totals
into numbers and we can do this a couple
different ways
for time i won't be going too much into
the math
of what it's doing but hopefully it
makes a lot of sense
so the first thing we're going to do is
count so i'm using
step under cf term frequency
and what it's doing is it's just saying
how many times does each word appear
in each observation so see right here
that the word table
appeared seven times in this one zero
times in this one
four times in this one and so on
um this doesn't um we can also do a
binary count so basically saying
did this word appear or not sometimes
doesn't matter
if a word up here one times 100 times as
long as it feel once
it's signal or not fast that's one way
of doing it
another way to do this is using
something called tf idf
so term frequency inverse
document frequency so we would say how
often
where it appears and multiply it with
how
not often it appears in many different
things so the word appears
in basically all the different documents
or observations
it appears almost always it has a really
high idf
and it doesn't weigh as much if it
appears
on their subset it starts appearing a
lot it becomes a kind of
normalization there's a bunch of
different ways they have to be
written now and we have most of the
variations
in this step as well there's also this
idea of feature hashing
so before we have
our tokens and we just say when they
appear
but we have to exclude a lot of totals
because
otherwise we have lighter
have like half a million tolerance and
we can't do that
and it has been super super sparse
because most pieces of
text don't contain
that large part of possible words used
so we use this thing called feature
hashing so feature hasn't been
hashing what it will do it will take
each token to a hash on it
that maps it to a number and then
we pin it according to that number using
a mod on it so right now we do
hashing on all different words do
mod 1025 and then the wires pop in right
here
and we can then in three here i'm saying
like if we're increasing
by decreasing the number of buckets in
future hashing
um we can with that some
collisions so multiple different words
will be
ending up in the same hash after we
take them out of it but it's a way of us
finding
a balancing act between
uh by finding a medium
um sparse uh implementation
main downside to this feature hashing is
you can't go backwards
we also have classical welding beddings
so this
targeted samples are wet to that fast
chest of glove very super
simplified view is we are making
we are building uh
that we are trying to map all words
all tokens into a multi-dimensional
uh space
so a point in space will represent one
token
and we try to build it to satisfy some
conditions of distances
and then we can use those vectors that
represent
each word later down the line
um in our framework since we're working
with
mostly tabular data i'm starting for
typical individual
we can't really do that as much we have
methods
in test recipes that will take find the
vectors
for each embedding vectors for each
token
and we can then combine them together so
we can assume them take the mean amounts
of them
they don't work well because it's just a
constraint but sometimes it can be
helpful
so we have that here we have word step
words embeddings
you divide embedding and say how to
activate it and you will do that
this doesn't work well all right so
um to kind of round it out one of the
reasons why i really like these
type based methods is because we did a
great deal of interpretation
on them so there's a lot of talk lately
we just heard
about algorithmic bias a lot of this
thought is related to
this large language models and one of
the issues these last language models
is they're very hard to tease out what
how they make those decisions and one of
the benefits of everything i've showed
so far
is most of these account based and
we also know time that many things so
it's feasible for a human
to go through all the different words
we're considering and see
is this the word to consider or not
so there is we can inspect our model a
little bit easier we use these simple
attack-based methods
and also a lot of them they work pretty
well like you can
generally my modeling advice is you
always start
low do something simple even if you can
start with a
linear regression model and build up but
sometimes
you don't need the multi-headed
multi-layer
deep neural network sometimes something
simpler will do it for you
and everything i talked about works as a
pre-processing step
so everything you'll do after that will
change how it is did before so are you
using this in trouble modeling are you
using to supervise modeling
things will matter depending on
how you do this last step of turning the
totals
into numbers you will produce something
very sparse or something
fast at all and the choice of model laid
up on the line
will make a difference if you want
to know more about all of this uh
as i said in the very beginning to the
city and i provided this bird
it goes much more in depth with
everything
everything i talked about so far covers
like the first third of the bird more or
less
the other two chapters there's much more
detail of all the translations you need
to do
how to remedy them then we go into
how to apply use tests in a supervised
sense both
with deep learning and non-deep learning
methods
and it's available for pre-order now at
most any online retailer
that
most online retailers that will uh
most other retailers that would sell a
very specific
and that is all i have you can find me
most everywhere online
uh using meal
with all of our thunderstorms anything
else
of course all the slides are created
with sewing gym
so that is all i have
thank you very much a big round of
applause virtually everybody
let's see those uh clap emojis in the
chat
and i'll make sure everyone can see me a
little golf clap here i see a few people
clapping in there
unfortunately we can't do what we do in
person giving you real applause everyone
here is talking
for you so that's very nice for
everybody
so i see there's we have a few questions
in there
i need to ask the last question first
because it's fresh and top of mind is
please pat your last name again slowly
so this person can sound smart saying
your name
all right so it's emil
so if you're any of anywhere close to
the southern border
you've heard the name emilio it's
without
eo that's the easiest way i've explained
people
and my last name is whitfeld
and if it's silent age silent d
can you spell phonetically in the chat
no i cannot
so and it's a fairly rare name where i'm
from as well so it's
oh wow so that doesn't help and the
person who asked that asked that in the
panelists thing
privately so i'm not going to name who
it is but i hope you person
um got that okay uh did ken brooks get
it right a vidfelt
yeah like i think that's the if you if
you read it like that most
americans will get it right all right
cool
i hope that's that question thank you
for that um then
questions about the talk um is there a
recommended
order of operation between normalization
tasks like two lower removing
punctuation
and tokenization it's like what is the
recommended order of operations there
yeah so uh so those two specifically
doesn't matter because
doing like a tokenization isn't affected
by
capitalization in english so for those
two it doesn't really matter
but the order does matter really when
you're working with stemming
and stopwatch removal
so some stop word lists most of them
worked
on fun stamped words but every once in a
while you will have a stopwatch list
that works with stemmed words
another thing if that i think that
happened in the sighted land
methods was most
words i think what it was that
words that was only two terrorists as
long as automatically removed
which of course like you have to know
that
beforehand because you might everything
else like breaks down if you don't
don't know that so it a lot of it if you
really want to know literally your stop
word list and that's the
look at your stop wait list look at all
the words do they make sense and
do they actually match out and look at
the
totals you have left after you remove
the stopwatch to see if some of them
slip through or not
okay and it's funny you mentioned um
looking at the stock word list i
remember the tag text package
had ways like to exclude stop words i
believe am i getting that correct
yeah so uh the the title package
has this uh
function that i think called that
stopwatch
that returns a tip of in using i think
it's the iso
smart and snowball stopwatch list all
today
and you just use a hand side join on it
and that if you're using the tidy tits
that's a pretty big stopwatch list
compared to just using the individual
ones
so you might remove words that you maybe
not have wanted to remove
especially all those little that list
will improve any kind
of pronouns so
if you need pronouns for some reason
then don't use that that list
all right this is coming from me now um
would you say this uh uh text recipes
supersedes tidy text
no it's a completely worse alongside
it i wouldn't recommend to use it as an
eda tool because
it doesn't it's not that transparent of
what happens
but once you know the transformations
you want to do
it puts in a rigorous framework to do it
well
okay but looking at what happens in the
intermediate steps of quite hard all
right
um the next question is any plans to
support hugging faces tokenizers in the
future
i have looked at it i need i haven't had
the most time to look at it yet
if someone already has
a r package that binds to it
i can add support for it if i have to
add support
for hearty phase totalizes enough it
will take proportionally as long time to
do it
but i would like to have support for
that because they do really pray for it
so it sounds like something john harmon
should do um he's in he's in the chat
john harmon i feel like hugging face is
your thing so i hope you will be uh
making this this contribution you'll
make a package of hugging face
then a meal can uh use that in text
recipes see open source working together
yeah and that's i think that to that
just hang like add on to that
i'm not i'm trying to rewrite as little
code as possible
like i'm trying to do but the total
message package
has a lot of big church masses i'm not
gonna touch i'm just gonna use it
like just to limit my load that makes
sense
um that's a good thing that's reused you
know open source
um in this step where you talk about
removing 50
um is there is a step spell check
i have been thinking about doing it that
the main
and it isn't really that hard it's just
a
modification on it it probably will
happen
but i have it on my list of things i
want to add it's always a little scary
because
you don't have a human actually changing
like overlooking what spell chats
are happening so it might actually
do everybody have sent the wrong test
it was spelled yet took over and
it had to be scary to put into
production
but i will add it eventually because
some people
want that's a good point too
um the question about your book uh does
the book cover
transformers and no it does not it
uh stops like shy
it then is a much simpler like we start
down low and build up and we don't go
that high
really it sounds like a second edition
thing
plan ahead got a plan plan after the
next edition another thing you're also
limited of what you can do easily enough
yeah so like that's that limited some of
the choices we have
um let's see that is a recent question
if you have new documents that you want
to compare to an existing corpus
is there a way to incrementally add it
to the embedding
but he had to do the whole thing all
over again
so if you're thinking of like i think
we're still live learning
is you can update an existing recipe and
that's a
recipe limitation of test recipe
limitations so if you have more training
data is what i'm reading
then you need to retrain the whole thing
is what i'm reading and that is not a
chest piece limitation that is a
recipe's limitation to do that
you of course if you're talking about
you have some data that you need more
transformations on
you can always apply your recipe to
these new observations
and do the transformation there
okay um
there was talk about space cr
is that a wrapper around the python
python library
yes so that is
space here i just wanted some names
i think this can be near it but
half of them but yeah that is a wrapper
around the
it's like an ah api wrap off that
uses fastly underneath the hood it can
be a little hard to work with simply
because
it's really hard to install r directly
python directly
when you're waiting with r so
once you get it installed it works well
right so like that yeah so it just uses
that and i'm trying
i have spent a couple of hours trying to
write a multi-raft wrapper
to sparsi instead of going through the
spacial
wrapper because i feel like i don't need
anything they need
so they're trying to dispatch your pet
is tries to do
everything sparsi can do
but they're not i don't need everything
i just need these pre-processing steps
so if i can do that we might have a
slightly faster implementation
um here's another question that just
came in
where does pos tagging come into
pre-processing
so uh we can do that as well instead
this is
included but if you're using like
esparza
any tokenizer that adds a part of speech
tapping there's steps to do that
that will like appear
like fairly fast after
you totemize but this is like
almost an enrichment step so you're
taking some of our totems
and modifying them so like
yeah like like somewhere in the middle
but that one shouldn't really be
affected too much of what happening
around
okay so somewhere in the middle um
then um
that reminds me of a question there used
to be a package i used called mighty
i believe i believe is an information
extractor
um i guess is that still like you say
our information extractors
um the old-fashioned ones made seven
years ago still relevant in today's
um with all with embeddings and hashings
and everything else
i don't know if i'm the right person to
answer that um
yeah i think that's the correct answer
all right here it is it's might it's
from mit nlp
it's the mit information extractor and
it looks like oh there was a commit a
month ago
to the right yeah yeah all right so
maybe this bill is being
actively developed all right um
and then this is um a question that's
the ud udpipe
or i guess you however you pronounce
that however you pronounce
what does that get you versus um some of
the other engines
so that engine is a trained
model much like despacia it's just a
different kind of model but it gives you
i think power speech and limitation as
well
so it's a more enriched
tokenizer but it's a trained model so
you need
like the actual trained object
as part of it all right and is that
different than udp
model or is udp model on a typo
it might be a typo okay might be top
type of the question
um we just got another question in um
what are some of your favorite
feature engineering examples using text
well so we have these general steps like
that like
these are like like almost like the
vanilla ones we're just counting things
but what we're talking about
you can all i like if you can find
some kind of domain knowledge so you can
always
craft all the things like can i
count the number of nouns and i found
like things like verbs can i
but basically you don't need to only use
these totals you can also
add in other functions do different
things calculate punctuation
calculate like even proportions or
things in it
in the boot we have an example
where there's a lot of censoring going
on in the document
of course if you actually what was that
data you you might be able to find
out the censoring but we had a lot of
account that credit card numbers
so they were like always like four four
four four four
four digits and if you did a normal
totalization on that
that would never that they would very
very repeat
but you could write as a function
that would just count how many times do
these trade top patterns appear
so instead of having 10 to 16
different credit cards you combine
everything into one
so you might get some signal that way so
i really like the handcraft box which is
all dependent on whatever you're doing
the one that takes the most work yeah
which are the hardest ones to write
about guitars and that's another thing
i'm
this is weird like different because i'm
not working with text on my day-to-day
so that's another thing is like i don't
have
right now i'm not lucky enough to work
with ted so i don't have
many recent examples
yeah make sense one day one day
anyone who has just throw a bucket of
text let's get all the text we can send
it send it to a meal
all right i will give everyone else just
one last chance to ask a question
uh if you have one now now's your time
to just slip it in right before the
deadline
uh for the buzzer because we are going
to call it in a little bit we'll just do
some wrap
ups and no one else has a question i'll
just give
another 30 seconds while i while we wait
these 30 seconds are a possible question
i want to say thank you emile uh this is
uh wonderful
um slide it
uh oh slighted i was trying to say
sliced
oh it's sliced yes if you want to talk
about slice i know julia's been on there
and a deer has been on there so yes go
ahead tell us about slice
i think that was a lot of slices right
like if you ever watched
the show chopped it i think i've heard
it's a similar form because nobody
actually watched chop but it's a
live two-hour uh data science
competition
they have four contestants they all
uh data data set that's too hard to do
something on it there's hidden
features so if they get special points
if they do
certain things that they don't know
beforehand that we need to do
and then they're judged uh we are wild
in the chat and if
i definitely i think they're starting an
hour by half an hour
on switch yeah
i forgot that it was tonight so yeah
folks go tune in next
is is it d rob and julia on it again
tonight or uh
not uh not today okay
i know josiah was on it not too long ago
josiah two weeks ago
julia a week ago next week after our
people we have
uh jessie master pat and dave robinson
yeah a lot of friends so so
folks these are people that have spoken
at the meet up in the conference
attended a lot so you can see if you
can't see each other in person yet
you can still uh see each other through
through this way finding the chat
yes and there's one more uh question
we'll sneak in we'll allow this last one
um do you have any general thoughts
about function words i.e pronouns
prepositions as a signal
so like they are sometimes useful
depending on what domain you're in
so of course if you for some reason
which
you probably rarely need to do but if
you really need to know someone's gender
pronouns are a great feature for that
but if you need to do
most everything else pronouns don't mean
anything
right i would say like that and only
like
and like one of my tastes is i feel like
you rarely need
gender anyway like that's very rarely
used at all
so but likewise pronouns don't help us
as much anyway but it could be
indicative of the type of test
so some types of like domains
don't use pronouns or really use
pronouns job listings
tend to not use pronouns um
that group chat probably uses them a
little bit more because we're talking
about each other
so it then as anything else it depends
favorite uh the favorite lawyer's answer
it depends
yeah okay right so
okay that's again virtual round of
applause
thank you thanks for having me thank you
for being here and this all happened by
the way folks
um we had a virtual meetup a couple
months ago
and i saw emil was in attendance i said
hey emil
send me a message you got to give a talk
and look at this it happens it's
happened a lot and i did
i did yes yes it actually worked and
this happens a lot there's been a number
of meetups where i saw someone in the
virtual crowd said hey
send me an email and give a talk and it
works so thank you emil for sending that
email
and uh being bold and following through
on that
uh to everyone remember we have a bunch
of events the next few months
we have the stan workshop july 14-16 we
have sean taylor july 13th
we have ian cook in august and we have
the conference and workshops for the
conference
september 1st then 9th through 10th so
thank you everyone for being here we'll
announce the next meetup soon and this
talk will be posted online
um very shortly and hopefully i'll see a
bunch of you
in person coming up and those who not
they'll still see you virtually
if anyone wants to give a talk send me a
message everyone once again another
big round of applause as loud as you can
make it i'm not gonna hear it
for emil thank you very much thank you
thank you
everyone have a good night